[Applause]
familiar slogans from the protests of
2018 and 2019
once again echo across sudan in the
capital cartoon hundreds took to the
streets to express their anger at what
they say is an attempt by the military
to disrupt the country's transition to
democracy
we were expecting a speedy transition to
civilian rule we don't actually feel
there is a transition to anything here
yet today there is no freedom peace or
justice in sudan
between sudan's military and civilian
politicians reached a low point this
week
after the recent attempted coup
when it took power two years ago the
transitional government promised to fix
decades of mismanagement internal
conflict and international sanctions
under the former president umar
al-bashir but it's yet to demonstrate to
the people of sudan that it can undo
damage done by bashir's regime
kick-start the country's struggling
economy and move the country towards
genuine democratic governance
what we need is to revamp and strengthen
government institutions especially our
weak institutions of justice only then
would we stop worrying about who rules
sudan
against all odds and most predictions
sudan's young people have in the past
built a peaceful and disciplined
movement that's all the toppling of one
of the world's most autocratic regimes
that of former president umar hassan
al-bashir and as the transition in their
country remains threatened by infighting
and squabbling within the sovereign
council
they're once again finding themselves
trying hard to get their voices heard
these protesters are also angry that
families of those who died during
protests two years ago are yet to get
justice
public discontent has also been mounting
over economic reforms that severely
reduced subsidies on petrol and diesel
more than doubling their price the
sudanese pound runs on several official
and black market rates and is
depreciating causing a loss of cash from
the formal economy these activists say
nothing will stop them achieving a
better way of life and they will bring
hope to a nation that's known little for
decades
mohammed al-jazeera
tom sudan